the answer is i think i'm already in my
mind on on social commerce 3.0 which is
the macro infrastructure like facebook
needs on the tv the hardware to be able
to you know see a commercial purchase it
and have target deliver it
because amazon's there
amazon's missing one thing
a social platform
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
hey gary thanks so much for joining us
today um i'm here with nick uh who
i believe is sitting in a room um full
of things that you've actually convinced
him to buy
pokemon cards to to whine um but you
know really what we're we're here to
talk about today is um we'd like to know
from you sort of what the future holds
um what are people missing um you know
at arc we we cover disruptive innovation
um which i've heard you say is uh you
think is is just being practical yes um
in your businesses uh so you know as as
we look at um this this wild year in the
digital economy and and sort of look at
the the future of the ad space we have
um consumers sitting at home uh
multitasking um using their connected
tvs while they're on twitter and other
platforms um how do you think of sort of
that juggling and and sort of that share
uh going forward and and sort of who who
loses who who wins out um what is sort
of the future state of that
you know it's interesting question given
the context of who i'm making an
assumption of is listening to this you
know as a
in perpetuity owner of my own businesses
with the ambition to buy the new york
jets football team
you know i play a very very very
different game than a lot of the
potential listeners of this show given
the context right and so so much of my
money has been made on my ability to
wait seven years for something to happen
versus being held accountable for what's
going to happen in 90 days or max
you know 500 days right so i could you
know i i i'm going through this very
interesting period in my life where i'm
like man
i'm definitely not so so so smart in
comparison to all these people i just
have the luxury
of
knowing how to stay alive to take
advantage of it when it happens i don't
think there's a single person listening
right now that is confused that ott and
streaming is 100
doing to cable and network what cable
and internet did to network what cable
did to network what network did to radio
this is like
i mean every single person in your and
my organization and listening to this
right now would probably bet the farm
the whole farm their kids health on a
decade from today things look more a lot
more like disney plus and and netflix
and hulu than they look like abc
or cbs or cnn and so i think the winners
are the ones that are in a financial
stable position to be able to invest in
streaming and take all that advertising
dollars that are never inevitably going
to come behind it and the losers are the
ones that are romantic or financially
stuck
in you know
milking what they have i mean it's very
common sense fortune 500 publicly traded
company logic versus reality of the
speed of innovation that's happening
with the internet
meaning
if you're the ceo of procter gamble
and or of you know of a large media
conglomerate you know um out there epic
you know or something of that nature
where
you know you're not gonna be in this
seat
in nine months or 18 months because
you've decided for your family and
yourself and you're striking all your
stock options within 24 or 36 months
after that day
and what you're doing is you're holding
your breath
and making no investments
so that you can maximize
your personal economics
41 months from now
but if you own the family business of
viacom you'd never do that
because you know exactly the consumer
has told you what's already happening so
i think the winners are the ones who can
or are or are
empowered by being historically correct
you know look at that look at themselves
as i'm going to be in this position for
six years so let me do this now i you
know ones that feel that they know how
to manage the street
to take the punch in the gut on the
upfront capital they're gonna have to
deploy
quibby's gonna scare the [ __ ] out of
people right
you know just because you have the right
just because you have the macro strategy
of streaming is real that's like me
telling everybody who's listening to
become an nba basketball player because
it's going to be a billion dollar
contract in the future you have to be
good enough to be an nba basketball
player so it's not just deciding to do
peacock how well
is nbc gonna execute peacock you know
it's not just saying that the
fragmentation of ott is upon us and the
ip within it like tomorrow the
kardashian family can start k
and probably do quite well
but they'll have to execute as well as
kylie's beauty brand
not as well as a million other things
we've seen fail
even though the ingredients are there
they didn't have the cook to cook it
yeah so gary there seems to be you know
two winners in this past year you have
the streaming the ott video but then
also you have social media companies and
they've really come on in terms of
digital ad spend so when you look at uh
smaller companies they're going to
obviously be you know more aligned with
social media it's just cheaper you're
not going to have a small company being
able to go to these streaming services
and advertise
you know what's funny though like you
know that's actually what excites me the
most brother i if if ott is biddable
you're going to find small businesses
running commercials on friends that's a
good point yeah right and like to me
like you know
the great luxury of my career at being
44 being young is i've already had real
significant chapters in very small smb
family liquor store business that i grew
quite a bit
a very big chapter in silicon valley
where i did a lot of smart investing and
then now really deep in fortune 500
consumer land and b2b land
you know
it's going to be pretty cool like i
think of gary at 22 knowing that hulu
ads are underpriced running commercials
for a one-story liquor store against the
wonder years that's like the coolest
[ __ ] ever right so yeah
but but to your but to your point
um
i think what you're gonna see is
look i i couldn't be more uncomfortably
bullish on ott and social over network
and traditional like it i think the
dealt is extreme
i think common sense is the great
missing anecdote of the business world
yeah and i think and i think reporting
and short-term financial arbitrage is
why
and i see it everywhere
um
but yeah i think those two platforms are
going to continue to be huge winners and
i would tell you
that this year them winning is not an
enigma because of the political year or
because of covid
this is the preview not the anomaly
right and so if you look at one of these
small businesses that want to spend on
streaming ott or social where is where
where are you directing those dollars
today where's the best bang for your
buck in terms of platform spent
if you're a tiny tiny business it's
linkedin and tick tock because they are
organic reach too
you know so organic is something we
don't talk a lot about but it's
absolutely the place where everybody
fails fortune 50 companies deciding
social media stinks because they're
running an organic playbook on platforms
that don't have organic reach and they
haven't even tested media properly or
they spend media on it like they're
running television
huge elephant in the room for everybody
who's listening right now why people
don't think socials roi positive comma
tiny tiny companies facebook it has
scale
targetability
and just ungodly proven capabilities of
driving business results
right and so so facebook seems to be far
and ahead of other competitors and on
the social landscape but
just let me give you some interesting
snap doing incredibly well for app
download snap doing incredibly well for
app so the answer is very very unique if
you're a t-shirt company
tick tock ads are remarkable if you're
you know the big thing that nobody
realizes is the number one the number
one place to advertise is 60 to 90 year
olds on facebook number one if you have
a business that wants to sell the 60 to
90 year olds
facebook dismantles
fox news television dismantles it
but yet nobody talks about that i mean i
would i think facebook is one of the
you know i'm a humongous advocate of its
ad product
but i think it's one of the worst comms
companies in the world and forget about
the whole like privacy thing in zucks
and all the all the stuff that people
get to of like hating it
i'm going super narrow
it has the killer product in the world
if you're trying to sell to 55 to 90
year olds and every media planner in
america buys television because they're
incentivized too because facebook's
harder to spend money on meaning you
need skills you have to do fragmentation
you need a lot of creative iteration
but
but facebook's a monster if you're
selling retirement homes caskets um you
know uh products that sell to 55 to 90
year olds um obviously tick tock is a
monster if you're selling a 15 to 25
instagram and youtube own the middle
snapchat if you're doing app downloads
is really attractive linkedin is a
monster b2b but nobody wants to pay the
25 cpms because everybody plays in media
math not in business math um you know
twitter is great for qualitative insight
to hypothesis around creative so i use
twitter a lot as a testbed for creative
to see consumers actual opinions of so
there's a lot this is real skill and
people continue to think of social media
as an afterthought but fortune 500
madison avenue mad men
are and women are starting to kind of
wake up but i still think we're 36
months away
from where coca-cola is spending 55 of
its ad budget on facebook inc and they
will
and you think that's going to come
mostly from that linear tv ad spend
like that seems to be the biggest bucket
i do yeah i think 70 billion
that 70 billion
is such garbage
yeah like like it is destroying the
biggest brands in the world now super
bowl is the best deal in advertising
every brand listening right now or
everybody who's got a board seat on a
consumer brand you should yell at the
top of the mountains once you cross your
t's and eyes on my hyperbole here to do
super bowl because the actual
consumption of the ad for what you pay
is remarkably cheap
right
after you go there
tv couldn't be a worse bet
now every report shows it's okay because
nielsen's and miller brown and all these
things it's an inside game all the mmas
internally have been built around it
it wait to the activist investors
realize how much money is being wasted
on marketing
all these activist investors have
focused on like flights and printing on
both sides of the paper wait to 3g wakes
up and realizes most of their marketing
goes in the garbage when they run a tv
and as you look over this past year and
um you know you said as we often find
with innovation things have accelerated
during this difficult time um how how
much how how how great do you think that
impact has been you said you think like
this
is three years
i'll tell you why it's been so big
it's because
decision makers became practitioners
during this time
cmos sit in boardrooms and have no idea
what's actually going on
there's no cans on keyboards people
don't actually know
right and agencies are all mainly owned
by holding companies who are publicly
traded who are going to keep pushing
television propaganda into their clients
because they make more margin selling tv
than they do on facebook
they're not incentivized their omnicom's
interests aren't aligned with fords by
the way on the record i have no idea if
that holding company works with that
brand but you know so so
the um the thing that i've noticed in
these nine months is getting a lot of
emails and linkedin messages from
leaders
with things that basically said i used
to think you were snake oil salesman but
now that i've had time to actually look
holy crap how can i get more educated on
this or hey can we talk so
i think
more than anything it's not even
consumer behavior acceleration
it's actually
decision makers
education of
that i think has serendipitously
happened during this era
do you think this change is permanent
yes
yeah if we're talking about what we're
talking about which yeah
yeah macro business how do we make
things how does the ecosystem work with
media brands opportunities yeah i think
it's permanent because i think
i i think you the thing that has always
worked for me is never betting against
the reality of the human being
like nobody's going back
there is no time machines
like i'm we're not going to read print
at scale
only hipsters out of ironic behavior
will
2029 queens might read the newspaper as
a nichey funny thing because they're
anti-establishment
there will be a wave of of
and we've seen it already of
anti-digital propaganda so you will see
some interesting sub-behaviors occur but
the sheer scale
of actual consumption on these 15
platforms youtube facebook snapchat
spotify on audio things of that nature
the cat's out of the bag
i i'm
flabbergasted other than being educated
and this is where wall street sometimes
gets caught
other than the fact that i'm educated
because i'm in it every day
had i not known that it was
in
agencies vested interest to not
allow the advancement of these products
which are much more complicated to run
planning execution creative media had i
not been educated on this i wouldn't be
able to understand why coca-cola and bmw
and proctor and unilever do what they're
doing i wouldn't understand nothing in
my brain would be able to put the pieces
together
because i do know i understand that it's
not in mind share
the agency that does media for
unilever's interest to do a contemporary
execution now i'm like oh i understand
and that is
the great detriment of
the iconic brands in the world which is
why you're seeing
so much growth on the ankle biter brands
on dtc because they're picking up market
share at scale on the back of
overvaluations
because there's so much money being
printed and yes their economics aren't
true but the problem is the unilevers
the proctors they go out and you m a
these brands and pay enormous amounts of
money
often that organ can't fit the body and
it becomes a failed m a instead of just
doing what they should be doing which is
completely changing their media and
creative strategies
gary i want to talk a bit about the
other side of this and that's the
content the content creation you have
all this money flowing into the
ecosystems and there are
millions of people signing up to be
content creators you talk to someone
who's younger they're saying i want to
be a youtube content creator how
sustainable is that market how big can
it grow it follows a power law
distribution you have ten percent of the
people making ninety percent of the
great qual content quality so how big is
that market going to be
as long as the internet is the
foundational
infrastructure of our society and as
long as it doesn't get over regulated
the answer is in perpetuity
until it takes all the money out of the
ivory towers
yeah
is is tick tock though the
tick tock really opened my eyes this
year in terms of uh democratizing
content creation and i i think of that
as a really powerful shift in the market
um
is it is it allowing you know is it
breaking down barriers for people to
create great content
of course it started with
instagram and snapchat
you started to see subtle training
wheels be put on content
i would argue in a lot of ways it
started with myspace but
which is true but
think about this twitter twitter comes
along and creates a restriction because
of sms protocol and creates a 140
character game
which inherently
creates a filter so really worked for a
guy like me that is very hot take driven
and very kind of like good at that thing
and that's why i grew and other people
who were more long-winded
really didn't even come onto the
platform for a long time because they
felt so
suppressed by that restriction then you
had instagram that made everybody a
better photographer literally a filter
that literally just one little thing
photos filters and it exploded because
it was training wheels to become a
better creator then snapchat came along
stickers ar right made people bet to
your answer better content creators tick
tock infuses music which inherently
makes everybody much better that becomes
a bigger training wheel and all of a
sudden people can come in so you've seen
the last half decade decade even
actually
become a game where
unlike facebook which was the dominant
player and even to some degree twitter
even though that had had that
restriction
the platforms that have gone on to
become the next big player have given
people a tool to create
and i think this will eventually lead to
things that look like what would adobe
look like
if adobe got very light
and
was the front end of a social network
like where this is all going is an
incredible suite of tools that are very
fast and lightweight that allow us to
make movies it feels like right you
would think that youtube
youtube is set to put an incredible
upfront production product
that can really take its platform or the
way to innovate and actually become the
next youtube is to be youtube with an
incredible
ai
ml
you know or just an incredible execution
of tools this has been one big game of
who can bring the most tools to make the
best creative or help people that are
average become better or great better
become great or great to become all time
boom boom boom that's what's happened
for the last 10 years yeah tick-tock
does seem to get a lot of roots from
youtube it was just built for mobile
right youtube is built for youtube
and this is what we've seen youtube has
done an incredibly bad job of innovating
like youtube had all the permission in
the world five years ago to come out
with something called why or yt or
whatever the hell they wanted to call it
and really build tick tock but a lot of
people try to defend the fort instead of
putting themselves out of business
yeah that's a good point
um i want to change tunes here a bit
because you do so much um one thing and
you you called yourself a hot tick guy
so i want to get your hot take on this
topic right here
um is texting replacing email we've seen
through this
okay there we go
definitive answer yeah and let me go to
where i know you're going to add value
because i don't think the context was
you know i was a bit of a little i'm
having a little fun here wine text and
oh by the way anybody who's listening
right now if you want to learn this and
make my father very happy because i
built this for him
you should go sign up for winetext.com i
built wine library in 1996 on the back
of email 90 open rates
no cost
texting does cost but text and commerce
and i think what we did with wine text
what i did with wine text
is really fascinating because i
eliminated friction in a way that is so
remarkable so for everybody who's
fascinated by what we're actually
talking about you can actually see this
in the wild as a preview to what i think
is going to happen at scale go to
winetext.com and sign up
yes i think email as a sales channel is
clearly been established as an
incredible and still to this day is an
incredible infrastructure but i do
believe sms
texting
has the potential to
become
the
establishment in five to ten years and
i've been blown away by the consumer
behavior on the back of wine text
yeah
sorry go ahead
what do you think are the limits of of
text
what are what are you finding sort of
is there is there a wall or sort of yeah
what fits best within that realm
uh you know to be very honest with you i
think it's exactly like email except
we created a ui that allows you to reply
with how many bottles you want it
becomes such limited friction
you know i think it's consumed i start
with attention
common sense and attention
is why i will buy the new york jets you
know like you know i start with the fact
that we live in our text sms and i and
then i and then what i layer what i've
done well in my 20 years is then once i
understand where the co where the
attention is i've always been thoughtful
enough to bring value to the consumer
versus value to me where everybody loses
is their content is selfish instead of
selfless or at least strategic where
you're bringing value and then you're
asking for something in return
you know i think where you'll lose if
you have a big sms strategy is you're
going to spam people and they're going
to unsubscribe
where you win is when you bring inherent
value and i think
you know not only with wine techs are we
bringing 80 wines for 35 bucks which
follows a groupon model that works and
because we have the infrastructure to be
able to deliver on that promise and it's
only 365 wines a year in a world where
we buy tens of thousands so you're going
to get 365 ridiculous deals
we're also very focused on educating
people we have very clear quant that
shows that if we only serve these seven
wines we would maximize our margin but
because i want it to be a learning tool
and expanding people's palettes i'm
taking less
dollars up front by getting people to
explore converts for meters and dessert
wines and champagnes but what that's
actually doing is making it a service
that's educating not just selling which
ltv wise will play out
so within even the e-commerce space you
think the limitations or there there
really are no limitations for tax or
there are certain types of goods that
will sell better inherently wine is the
perfect example well to your point if
you have a clothing item you might have
some more syntax issues where you got to
talk about size and this and there's
going to be clearly if you're selling
the unit as is and there's no
alterations
everything will do well a fork you know
a hat
you know
sneakers if you just reply with you know
you know if there's a cadence of size
yeah
it's i think the prize is going to be so
lucrative that people will innovate to
eliminate the limitations
yeah
and what about what about platforms like
slack
do you see them coming into play like
what's what's next after a text
well i mean look i mean
whether it's slack or whatsapp or
messenger or other thing you know china
is advantage of being a communist
country which gave those companies the
ability to
hold off their competition be vertically
integrated and and play politics and
good innovation and just scale that is
unheard i mean i
i'm so fascinated by people that don't
have context on the chinese market you
know whether it's live streaming or how
much an influencer because i mean when i
say things to people like you know when
influencers sold 60 million dollars
worth of this one product on one live
stream they an american business
person's brain breaks because they're if
they're not being global about this so
you know i think i think
i think what's i i do think there's a
ton of innovation in the american market
let me phrase outside of the chinese
market around live
i think there's a ton on that
um but it's all the same game whether
you're youtube or spotify or facebook i
believe all three of you all three of
those companies are in the same business
they're they need to show me that they
can vertically integrate with retail i'm
shocked that nobody's bought target yet
like like i'm convinced that
that facebook or tick tock or that
somebody in content buys
buys target you know i think walmart
going to the tick tock route makes a ton
of sense it's what amazon has over
everybody i don't think i'm stunned by
the big tech company's lack of
understanding that retail is a component
of the stack
and so i think target's a huge target
for m a activity from a facebook or an
apple or spotify
because i think retail is an actual part
of the macro stack of the biggest
companies in the world and i think you
can see that with amazon's leverage you
can see that
um
you know with content amazon prime is a
leverage point against you know
the video product against selling on its
site walmart's going to need to
replicate that
facebook's going to find itself facebook
is incredible in m a around its core
strength of attention but i think they
have to integrate hardware and retail to
be a full stack monster and so i'm
waiting for the companies in america to
wake up to that full stack and we've
seen it with amazon's seen it the most
prime whole foods these are not by
accidents i think bezos continues to
outmaneuver his competition
so how big do you think that opportunity
is we we've kind of coined it as social
commerce i think that's what you're
touching on here this idea that mac but
it's matt you see where i'm going you're
i know where you're going with social
commerce live shopping cart it's huge
i think it extends beyond that i think
think about it if if facebook owns
target tomorrow and you're in feed and
you could buy something but you could
pick it up at the register if you want
you know or all those locations like
the answer is i think i'm already in my
mind on on social commerce 3.0 which is
the macro infrastructure like facebook
feeds on the tv the hardware to be able
to you know see a commercial purchase it
and have target deliver it
because amazon's there
amazon's missing one thing
a social platform
so then who in your mind is winning
social commerce 1.0 or 2.0 wherever
you're at and or wherever it is
the human beings that are arbitraging
the platforms
so the shopify's the shopify droppings
yeah exactly the humans not the
platforms the platforms are fragmented
somebody's going to m a their way
somebody's going to pull off the bob
iger moment bob iger figured out that
the ip was the value and he went over
paid for lucas and marvel only to be
proven to be historically true with
disney plus
somebody of the amazon google facebook
inc snap spotify i think is a sneaky
competitor to all this because they can
add they can add video and boom like
some of those six people seven people
that have the attention are gonna add
hardware and
and social and and retail and win the
game like apple buying target would make
sense you know
you know
facebook
facebook i'm stunned that facebook
hasn't gone there
because they have so much to lose
against walmart and amazon if walmart
and amazon buy twitter like there's a
lot here and it's gonna go that route
and so so you're saying amazon is
already there in a lot of ways amazon's
there if if amazon goes and buys twitter
tomorrow they've completed the loop
they're they're in hardware at some
level and with voice and i think they
should build i think all of them should
make a television a dumb television
that's just
tricked out for no money get in homes
like to me i'm to me i'm buying a
television and and
losing i'm doing the i'm doing the razer
and video game business where i'm losing
money
on the television that's tricked out
just to get you into my ios
yeah
but then how many players do you see in
that ecosystem because it does seem like
it has like winner takes most
characteristics three right you know how
it all plays out at scale right
a and a b competing with a distance c i
think q srs help us with that right
mcdonald's burger king and there's wendy
and then change thing will come along
and chicken sandwiches matter like you
know but like i think i think
three feels very right five
if you're fragmenting it out
so do you think it's harder to go from
the social to the hardware and the other
macro pieces like facebook would have to
get completely casting based on the ceo
okay i mean it's money and testing it's
who has vision
you know
it's who has vision it's like i'm a
hundred percent positive what i'm saying
is right and will play out
yeah and that's called vision that's
understanding consumer that's
understanding business dynamics and
historical trends and pattern
recognition
and and now it
it's why
it's i've always been historically i
used to get booed at south by on my take
on bezos versus steve jobs something
about the way jeff has played always
made me feel like he saw it the most and
i think
they're awfully close
right they've got you know
they're awfully close man they're
awfully close i think they do need the
social
the one piece they're missing is the
social component and i think
you know if i'm bezos i put up a billion
dollars for internal
creation and just go or i go out and try
to buy twitter
um
probably what about what about uh buying
a gaming company because that seems to
be like the new social or the next wave
in social are these these games
that's easier because you're buying a
production company because to amazon's
point they have twitch
right
facebook when i inquired mixer from
microsoft microsoft by the other way is
the other sneaky one i've been very
impressed with the microsoft ceo you
know i i've been very bullish on
microsoft
um i think they've been very smart i
think linkedin was a monster move into
the thing that i talk about as that's
become more of a social network and i
think they just have to innovate
um a little bit more i could see them
going into the hardware play heavy with
xbox like come out with xbox tv or xtv
if you don't want to alienate and make
it to like somebody's gotta create the
lost leader television that's stacked
with their ios that is the game in a lot
of ways where you can do social shopping
or video shopping within it if you have
the retail infrastructure again
microsoft launches at x
television goes and buys target and
we're watching commercials
on x television through their ios like a
roku or thing like that nature and i
click a button and targets deliver you
see where this is going
it's a subscription for all of your
services correct there's no reason not
to yeah it's the ultimate subscription
at the end of the day and whoever
controls the person's face wins which is
why apple's blown it which is why i've
always been down on what cook's done
they owned this remote control and they
didn't layer on top of it
and there's really two remote controls
this and the television so everybody
who's in that game get a remote control
get to the front of the screen and then
build the stack underneath it that is
the game that is the trillion dollar
warfare so even with that i want to
write a book called trillion dollar wars
with the seven logos we just said and
lay out the hypothesis i cannot wait to
have this video playing in six years as
a split screen of i told you so because
it's 100 gonna happen
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this
is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon